es ist ein altes schweizer volkslied und
wird es heute gesungen trifft es immer
noch mitten ins herz
doch singen berührt nicht nur singen
kann auch schockieren singen stärkt die
gemeinschaft und macht mut als nur emi
nadelmann 2011 im bundeshaus die
nationalhymne anstimmte ver stunden
sogar die politik wer singt verschafft
sich respekt
einer der auszog um zu beweisen dass
singen glücklich macht ist bernhard
furtner
in vier schweizer städten leitete er den
chor der nationen 250 laien aus 30
nationen im singen finden sie eine
gemeinsame stimme singen über alle
grenzen hinweg musikalische und
sprachliche das befreit
dazu dass das einmal den kick
mitzusingen treibt er noch ein stück
weiter sein herz der britische
chordirigent bringt alljährlich 1300
leyen dazu die berliner philharmonie
erklingen zu lassen
ich glaube alle können singen
es ist mir nicht wichtig wie man singt
und woher besingen kommt es ist nur
wichtig dass alle haben freude für musik
wenn herr sie ruft dann eilen diesing
heutigen in schaan das bad in der menge
förderte erst recht die glücksgefühle
singen gilt als urform der menschlichen
emotionen
was gibt es da schöneres als neu
entdecktes in talente wird einfach
endlich das machen und ich schaue mich
ganz klar wir fiebern mit bei tv shows
mit singenden busfahrerin und trauern
wenn sie am musikhimmel verglühen und
die profis regula mühlemann ist
angehender opernstar nach jahrelanger
ausbildung ist sie eine gefragte
sopranistin auf den ganz großen bühnen
das macht mich glücklich
es ist mein job ist es halt ein
singen macht glücklich auch wenn nicht
an jedem ort jeder zuhörer das
glücksgefühl teilt